hey what is up guys I'm Kay PhD here and
yesterday the motox was finally unveiled
or revealed to the public for the first
time and it was announced in all the
specs everything is official now and so
naturally all the tech blogs did their
hands-on and first impressions and
compared us to everything possible and a
blitz of coverage and that's nice but so
I have a moto X so there's that and I've
gotten a lot of experience with the
basics of how this device works why it
does what it does and why it has the
features that it does so this is the
Moto X features explain first of all I
want to say that a lot of the buzz about
this phone is about the launch price of
200 dollars on contract how can you
charge $200 for a phone that seems like
it has mid-range specs you know what
else has 200 bucks on contract price
this Samsung Galaxy s4 the HTC One the
iPhone 5 these are all the highest end
phones from these respective companies
and they all have high-end specs but
those specs are really just numbers on
paper to begin with I mean a 720p
display versus a 1080p display a
dual-core versus a quad-core processor a
2200 million power battery versus a 2600
milliamp hour battery these are really
just numbers and the average consumer
doesn't care too much about the numbers
behind a phone as a matter of fact I can
guarantee you pretty much everyone who
complains about the Moto X as specs is a
geek but that's the thing motorola isn't
selling the phone to us geeks at least
they're not trying to they're trying to
sell this phone to the average person
we've seen this approach just like
Samsung took it with the galaxy s4
samsung took the approach of adding tons
of WoW features that blow your mind
motorola has seen the same thing and
adding value via software instead of
hardware is really why the Moto X is
going the direction that it does so the
first of these features that Motorola is
trying to woo the average consumer in
with is their voice activation and they
call it touchless control so you've
probably already seen the galaxy s4
features where you can control your
phone without touching it you know you
can wave your hand over the screen to
change pages you can scroll up and down
webpages with your eyes all these
or physical gesture based things to try
to impress you motorola is counting on
the fact that you'll like
voice-activated stuff so if you ever
want to use your phone just without
touching ever at all you can see the
Moto X behind me right there for this
demo I want to know the weather outside
all I have to do is use my voice to
generate that key phrase and it will
follow up so uh okay Google now what's
the weather if I want to just know the
weather outside without touching it so
you can see that they're banking on this
kind of stuff to impress the average
consumer what other phone does that
right now every other phone that you
want to find out the weather with you
have to take it out your pocket unlock
it and start figuring it out with an app
all you have to do is ask the phone what
the weather is it's kind of like that
Star Trek stuff where you can just talk
to the computer in the sky and it
responds to you it's pretty impressive
and I think that's definitely the
biggest thing that they can use right
now and the Moto X to get people to buy
it
okay Google now what is the capital of
the United States Washington DC is the
capital of United States of America
didn't even have to touch it okay Google
now what is the population of Australia
the population of Australia was twenty
two point three two million in 2011
okay Google now how tall is Yong Ming
Yao Ming is seven feet six inches tall
okay google now who is he married to
yell Ming spouses eally since 2007 it's
pretty impressed with the next video
feature on the Moto X is what's called
peak mode with the notifications it
seems minor but imagine someone walking
into a store and the sales are up going
hey alright you want a new phone every
other phone in here if you want to check
your notifications on the time what you
have to do is take it out your pocket
wake it up unlock it check the time
check the notifications close it back
down lock it up and then put it back in
your pocket that's the process you have
to go through with every other phone
with this Moto X though right here all
you have to do is you want to know the
timing your notifications just take it
out your pocket it knows when it's been
take out your pocket you can
peak to view the notifications if you
have any you can check them the time is
already there and once you're done just
put it back in your pocket and it locks
by itself all right so you know that
secret Google Motorola event that kind
of happened a couple of weeks ago that
no one was supposed to talk about well
now we can talk about it and yes I was
there and while I was there
Guy Kawasaki was explaining to me why he
feels that this next feature was akin to
what Apple did with the first colored
IMAX on the Moto X you can customize the
back color the front color the trim
color the back and graving and the boot
up screen animation with the Moto X no
other phone can do this and it'll
probably be a while before any other
phone can I think there's a certain
satisfaction people get out of being
able to design and create their own
things and I think the Moto maker
experience really nails it it's very
similar to the Nike ID shoe
customization process where you can
share the design you made with someone
else and they can view your exact design
you can go ahead and mess around with
your favorite colors pick the designs
you want pick the accessories make
everything match up basically speck out
the exact phone that you would have
wanted with all the trim color on the
back and front face and color and
everything like that
choose your storage size your case
everything and you can come back to it
save it come back to it later and really
make it your own before you decide to
buy it
the only massive massive flaw with this
is that this is only available for the
18 T Moto X Motorola if you're listening
that is the dumbest thing you could have
possibly done with this because this is
easily the most unique feature about the
Moto X is hardware and honestly I really
hope this exclusivity ends as soon as
possible so there's also a new clear
pixel camera on the back of the Moto X
it's a 10 megapixel shooter has an extra
clear sensor to get much better
low-light shots and much faster shutter
speeds but what's going to blow people's
mind about this and what's really an
important feature to sell to the average
person is in order to open the camera
all you have to do is take it out your
pocket and shake it like that and
without even touching the screen I'm
already now able to take pictures and
this is important because when someone
walks into the store and sees that and I
ask the sales rep well does the galaxy
s4 do that no does the HTC One do that
no does the iPhone do that no say iPhone
do that nope yeah I think I'm going to
get this one this is pretty impressive
another thing is a battery life on
phone now I haven't been able to kill
this phone in one full day of use
meaning waking up at nine o'clock and
going to sleep the next morning at 2:00
a.m. I haven't been able to kill this
phone it is said to have a useful 24
hour battery life I haven't been able to
get that much continuous use with it but
I can guarantee you this thing is a
power sipper it is an incredible power
manager and it's most likely in part due
to that XA chip inside which has a lot
of different cores dedicated to managing
different things but that doesn't even
matter to the average consumer that is
another spec sheet thing that they don't
want to hear all they hear is this phone
has a 24 hour battery life and none of
the others do except Motorola's RAZR
MAXX but again this one looks cooler you
can make a purple one so combining all
these features together that's really
what makes the Moto X a much more
appealing to the mass market that's
really who this phone is aimed for again
and this is why it has all the features
that it does it's got it's a
good-looking phone it's a good feeling
phone in the hand break compact it's got
an edge to edge display and it's got a
lot of features that are all geared
towards the average consumer the
mass-market because they want to sell as
many of these guys as possible in the
United States and that is the Moto X's
features explain know what this entire
video can be summarized with one frame
check us out check this out geeks value
specs versus price consumers value
features versus price when you market a
phone towards geeks you focus on those
specs when you market a phone towards
the average person you focus on those
features for us geeks and tech
enthusiasts there is going to be a
Google Play edition of the Moto X so
expect to see that in the next couple of
weeks and it will likely have you know
pure stock Android on it and it will be
missing a lot of the Motorola features
that US geeks would consider gimmicks
but again for now the Moto X is supposed
to be Google and Motorola big seller so
expect to see ads of all these things
that we consider gimmicks on TV and all
over the internet but until then this is
not the four of you this is just the
beginning of my coverage of this
impressive little device here the Moto X
stay tuned for all the rest of the
coverage feel free to leave a thumbs up
below if you enjoyed this video but more
importantly subscribe so you can get the
rest
my videos on the Moto X and all sorts of
other things that I have coming up in
these next few weeks months and years
down the road either way thank you for
watching and I will talk to you guys in
the next video Basin